formation et innovation deux mots clés
de la venue de gérard larcher président
du sénat à bois d'arcy lundi 25 avril
au programme visite de deux des 70
entreprises de la zone arcisienne
delacroix bonnet première étape la
plateforme de service après vente du
groupe l'ipsi implantée sur le site
depuis 2012 c'est un bassin où les
chiffres de l'emploi sont plutôt bons et
font rêver
dans le reste du pays c'est en même
temps on le voit bien une période qui
n'est pas facile où les communautés
d'agglo doivent se battre pour le
développement économique
écarté la croix boon est un grand centre
économique pour bonnart 6 avec des
fleurons industriels
hilti leroy merlin leclercdrive voiron
voilà ce sont des grandes entreprises
suite à un incendie des locaux hilti de
magny les hameaux en 2012 l'entreprise a
choisi bois d'arcy pour reconstruire ses
9000 m² dédiés au service après vente
la structure intégrée un centre de
formation national afin d'accompagner au
mieux les mille quatre cent cinquante
salariés dits petits france le service
apprenant c'est très important pour nous
c'est un des services qui différencie de
la concurrence et donc c'est un lieu
d'expertisé aussi et donc on s'est dit
on va mettre l'information même endroit
voulait pas de formation hors sol
l'information qu'ils soient loin du
terrain loin des préoccupations
opérationnel un des facteurs de la
compétitivité c'est la formation
initiale c'est la formation
je crois que c'est une des forces
notamment de l'économie allemande
il y en a d'autres éléments mais la
formation initiale nous n'avons pas
encore résolu tout à fait cela dans
notre pays
la visite s'est ensuite poursuivie au
leclerc drive situe également à la croix
baudet une structure implantée sur bois
d'arcy depuis 2014
gérard larcher a ensuite conclu sa
visite par une rencontre avec les élus
de la majorité municipale